sorpresa para la unión europea tras el
pacto alcanzado entre eeuu australia y
reino unido- este acuerdo de defensa
para hacer frente a china se trata de un
acuerdo con unas negociaciones de las
que la comisión europea no tenía ningún
tipo de conocimiento según ha reconocido
hoy justamente cuando son tres aliados
clave en las relaciones exteriores de la
unión europea además se produce justo
cuando hoy el jefe de la diplomacia
europea josep borrell ha presentado la
nueva estrategia del bloque de cara a la
región indo pacífica una región muy
importante que justamente lo que busca
es contrarrestar la influencia de china
en esta zona a través de mayores pactos
comerciales y también mayores
inversiones en todo caso está este
acuerdo ha sido una sorpresa tampoco se
ha podido esconder el malestar que ha
provocado más aún cuando ayer la
presencia de la comisión europea úrsula
von der leyen desveló en su debate del
estado de la unión y la creación de un
pacto global para hacer frente al
conocido como ruta de la seda china y
también pidió mayor autonomía en defensa
sin embargo este acuerdo entre estos
tres países podría hacer replantear a la
unión europea a su papel en el mundo más
aún cuando estos socios tan claves han
decidido no contar con la unión europea
en algo tan importante como es
contrarrestar el auge de china